the family of a woman who recently moved  to las vegas is searching for answers  after she went missing briana davis  moved from california to las vegas with  her boyfriend in february  her sister says she talked to davis  every single day  until march 31st her sister says davis's  boyfriend told them that she was missing  days ago and she also says that he keeps  changing his story saying at first davis  was picked up in the middle of the night  and then saying that she went to  7-eleven and never came back  no contact no one's seen her  the boyfriend is acting very suspicious  he's not answering our phone calls  sister also says that she's no longer  active on social media  metro police are looking for her but  they haven't said if this case is  suspicious so if you do know anything  though about her disappearance call  metro that number is on your screen